You think sloths are cute?
Just wait til you see what they looked like
5 million years ago!
Not gonna lie - it's kinda terrifying.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and believe
it or not, the cute furry little sloths you
see today are NOT the ones that existed millions
of years ago.
Back then, they were enormous creatures that
walked on hind legs, and were nowhere near
as cute as their modern descendents.
Sloths actually belong to the same family
of creatures as armadillos and anteaters,
and they're all part of the superorder Xenarthra,
which originated in South America almost 60
million years ago.
Obviously, sloths today look nothing like
armadillos or anteaters - but back then, they
all shared common features.
They had some of the lowest metabolisms of
any mammals, and all of them had extra joints
in their lower spine to aids in digging, which
is primarily how anteaters and armadillos
find food.
Eventually, when North and South America fused
together around 3 million years ago, many
of the ground sloths that were once exclusive
to South America, migrated upwards - populating
the entire Western Hemisphere, where they
continued to thrive for millions of years.
Now if you're wondering how an extremely slow
tree-dwelling animal managed to survive an
era that killed off creatures way bigger and
stronger than them, it's because sloths back
then were nothing like the sloths we know
today.
They all lived on the ground, and some even
evolved into aquatic mammals.
The Megatherium, for example, which populated
South America around 500,000 years ago - was
a gigantic creature the size of an elephant.
It weighed several tons and lived a full and
active life on the ground, roaming alongside
giant armadillos the size of rhinos.
Eventually, Megatheriums evolved into what
we now know as the three-toed sloth.
But two-toed sloths evolved from a different
genus called Megalonyx, which consisted of
a slightly smaller - but still enormous - species
of ground-dwelling sloths.
Two-toed and three-toed sloths are actually
a great example of convergent evolution.
Both species likely shared a common ancestor
around 35-40 million years ago, after which
point they evolved separately, developing
many of the same characteristics.
They became smaller, and their size, along
with their strong arms and hooked claws, is
likely what turned them into tree-dwelling
creatures.
Although no one knows exactly WHEN that happened,
because there are no existing fossil records
of sloths that lived in trees.
So how did they evolve to hang upside-down?
Well, it probably has to do with their low
metabolism.
Running along the top of a tree branch requires
balance, and thus energy.
So by hanging underneath a branch - which
is easy for a creature with the arm strength
of sloth - it allows them to conserve energy.
It also looks really cute - which is perhaps
the most important thing of all.
What about y'all, are you as surprised as
I am at how these little guys used to look?
Let us know in the comments below, and remember
- it's Sloth Week all week long!
So if you want more even more videos to fawn
over, you can check em out over on the Animalist
YouTube channel, or just head over to slothweek.com.
And we'll put a link in the description below
as well, just in case!
That's it for me, thanks for watching - and
for more DNews, just subscribe here.